views and opinions expressed on this
program are those of the guests
appearing on the program
and do not necessarily reflect the views
and opinions of eight news now
or next our media group the case against
donald trump
and mike pence is open and shut tonight
on politics now joe biden picks kamala
harris as his running mate
the swift reaction to the choice from
both sides plus
the thing about information security is
there's no finish line
[Music]
protecting our election what nevada is
doing to stave off cyber attacks
as republicans criticize the process and
china needs to be held accountable
republican congressional district 4
candidate jim marchand
talks about the coronavirus pandemic the
economy
and what he would do about it all if
elected
from 8 news now this is politics now
[Music]
joe biden has finally picked his running
mate california senator kamala harris
thanks so much for joining us i'm
kirstjen joyce john langler is on
vacation this week
biden and harris through a kickoff on
wednesday joe khalil
was there to tell us what happened on
january 20th
2021 we're all going to watch senator
harris
raise her right hand and swear
the oath of office the biden campaign
made it official today
i picked the right person to join me as
the next vice president united states of
america and that's senator
kamala harris naming california senator
kamala harris as joe biden's running
mate
the first asian-american and
african-american woman
chosen for the role on a presidential
ticket biden called harris a fighter
and acknowledged the history her
candidacy makes
this morning all across the nation
little girls woke up especially little
black and brown girls
who so often feel overlooked and
undervalued
in their communities but today today
just
maybe they're seeing themselves for the
first time in a new way as the stuff of
president
joe likes to say that character is on
the ballot and it's true
in her first remarks as running mate
senator harris repeated the mantra of
the campaign
saying she'll continue the fight for the
soul of the nation
and the case against donald trump and
mike pence
is open and shut she went after the
trump administration on its coronavirus
response
more than 165 thousand lives
cut short when other countries are
following the science
trump pushed miracle cures he saw on fox
news
and biden with his new partner
kamala they want to increase regulations
and that's just going to drive
companies out and it's going to drive
people out president trump pushed back
wednesday night at his press briefing
he also wasted no time in going after
harris
minutes after her name was announced
tuesday he tweeted an attack ad produced
by the trump campaign
slo joe and phony kamala perfect
together
wrong for america wednesday night
president trump associated the biden
harris campaign with antifa
in my book it's virtually a part of
their campaign antifa
the democrats act like gee i don't know
exactly what that is
and both sides criticized each other's
economic policies wednesday
something we'll likely see continue as
both campaigns move forward
in washington i'm joe khalil
as you would expect democrats praised
the move by biden to pick harris
republicans criticized it
trump's nevada campaign said quote
kamala harris has solidified joe biden's
campaign as the most radical ticket in
history the only way to stop their
dangerous agenda is to re-elect
president trump in november
now nevada democrats all scrambled to
post pictures they took with harris
during the campaign
state democratic party chairman william
mccurdy said quote there is no doubt
biden and harris are a winning ticket
hailing from california
senator harris represents the diversity
of the west
end end quote the democratic national
convention is next week and the
republican national convention starts
the week of august 24th
eight news now this morning anchor alex
back has talked with alexander limon
from the washington d.c bureau
about what we can expect should we start
with the dnc
first i know there's a lot of changes
this year because it's going mostly
virtual so what do we know
that will be different so far that's
right both conventions are going to be
pretty
unconventional you know early on the dnc
scrapped their plans for a big in-person
convention
you know packed with tons of people
inside the milwaukee convention center
they also did away with plans for caucus
meetings and happy hours and all of
those festivities
that you would normally see associated
with a convention a presidential
convention however the dnc was still
hoping to be able to have the main
keynote speakers
um people like nevada senator cortez
masto
on monday the now vp pick
kamala harris and of course joe biden
people like that
all speak in person in milwaukee but
they've now also
scrapped those plans all together we
know that joe biden will be speaking
from his home state of delaware instead
so
there will be no in-person activity we
always have a few more days to prepare
for the rnc at this point and so many
things have changed in recent weeks with
that as well
will that also be mostly virtual or what
do you expect to see there
everything is changing and happening at
the last minute for both conventions
but the latest guidance that we have
from the republican party
is that they still plan to have some
in-person activities
in charlotte north carolina they say
that six delegates
from each state and u.s territory
will be attending and having some caucus
meetings
in person however uh as far as we know
we believe those will all be
private so the public i'm not sure how
much media access will be available
again because they say they're trying to
limit the total number of people
that are present we don't have
a specific schedule night by night of
who
keynote speakers would be if any if
those would be in person
or virtual all of those are still up in
the air but again the rnc is uh
one week later so all of these details
are coming together pretty last minute
we do know that president trump does
plan on speaking
when he accepts the nomination however
we don't know
uh where that will happen the president
has floated the idea of possibly doing
it in
gettysburg or at the white house
and again thanks to alex backus and
alexander limon for that
as she mentioned president trump will be
giving most likely his acceptance speech
from the white house now president trump
continues to criticize nevada's expanded
mail-in november
election plan he's even filed a lawsuit
to stop it
here's what he had to say during a press
conference before
filing that lawsuit last week i just
want to point out we did call nevada's
secretary of state's office election
division and the spokeswoman there said
that that
simply isn't true mr president and that
nevada will continue to check ballot
signatures against voter registration
cards
it's done at the county level okay but
that's not what they said when they
approved it they said they're not going
to check signatures they're not going to
be able to
and their machinery which is old doesn't
allow them to so they're going to be
it's going to be physically impossible
for them to do that
for the record nevada does have
signature verification
on our mail-in ballots and did use it in
the june primary
nevada secretary of state barbara
sagavsky who is a republican
asked a judge to dismiss the lawsuit
this week she says it is a policy debate
that should occur
outside of a courtroom and the trump
campaign has not explained how it would
be harmed she says by changes in the law
the judge has not ruled yet so how will
our state election officials plan to
keep our election safe and secure
john langler reports it's one of the
most important decisions you can make
where to place your vote it's up to
election officials to keep your votes
safe
the thing about information security is
there's no finish line
wayne thorley is deputy secretary of
state for nevada elections
he is well aware of how crucial it is to
protect the election from hackers and
cyber warfare
it is absolutely a real threat
any information system that you have
comes with a risk and we use a lot of
information systems when it comes to
elections
as far as the actual vote thorley says
the ballot system is not connected to
the internet
insulating it from cyber attacks it's a
standard way to safeguard your ballot
called an
error gap but it's not just voting
election officials have to protect
there's online registration and the
publication of results online
as we go more and more online with more
and more
electronic information systems
those risks don't go away but we have we
just have to be aware of them
john langler eight news now
this week governor sissel act signed a
law creating coronavirus liability
protections
for nevada businesses it's about
acknowledging
that nevada relies heavily on a single
industry
the hospitality industry in order to
make it through this historic storm
we must ensure that that industry
survives
sisalak went on to say the following
that senate bill
4 was passed during the second special
session giving limited immunity for
businesses non-profits and government
agencies
against people suing them for
contracting covet now as long as the
business has taken appropriate steps for
safety and sanitation
it does exclude schools and health care
entities
like hospitals so they could still face
some lawsuits
it does include extra worker protections
for people in the hospitality industry
the nevada hospital association called
the bill disappointing
since it was excluded
what should we do at the border i'm
agreeing with what president
trump is uh so far what his policies are
with daca
republican congressional candidate jim
marchant weighs in on immigration
and his coronavirus plan plus
congresswoman susie lee tells us what
she would have done different in the
coronavirus response plan it's all
coming up next on politics
yes
welcome back to politics now
with less than 90 days until the
november election we want to zero in on
some of the congressional races that
will be tightly contested
in congressional district four incumbent
democrat stephen horsford faces
republican jim marchant
marchand is a former assemblyman in the
state legislature and has started and
run computer and software companies
john langler interviewed him about the
race how would you
characterize the response not only on a
local level but
as a potential congressman on a federal
level
well i think trump is doing about as
good as anybody
could have done uh you know this copa
virus was
unprecedented i don't know that anybody
or this whole world has experienced
anything like this and uh so i think
he's done
probably as good as anybody could have
expected
i mean everybody actually whether it's
local or
federal you know this is all new
territory here
so we have to learn on the job
so are you you're satisfied with how the
benefits have been uh handled on in
washington
how the testing has been handled in
washington
uh yeah pretty much um the of course i
would like the benefits to
to come out more and i'd like to get
politics out of the way
right now the bill is being held up for
political reasons and people are
suffering and i don't like that
also china needs to be held accountable
uh whether they did this with malice or
or
accident uh they didn't they tried to
cover it up
and we definitely need to hold them
accountable for
what's going on there we both know how
much the
the pandemic has affected las vegas and
the valley and the tourism industry
um what would you do if elected to
um try and make things right try and get
las vegas and and
broadly your constituents back on track
and i guess more by extension how does
it differ from your opponent
well first of all i would like to get
our economy open
as fast as possible and as safely as
possible
and the difference between myself and my
opponent is i am a free market
type businessman and economy is very
important to me i think i know how to
the policies that will affect the
economy
positively and my opponent is a
socialist
so he wants higher uh more government
more taxes and bills and policies
that kill our uh economy switching gears
a little bit to
uh the issue of immigration daca there's
been some
movement on that from from the white
house on this recently
what is your position on extending or
restricting daca moving forward
and what should be done at the board
i think that uh i'm agreeing with what
president
trump is is uh so far what his policies
are with daca
uh giving them a a pathway forward
but i don't want amnesty i don't mind uh
making them legal in some way where they
can get a work visa or something like
that
in other words the parents of the of the
dreamers
where they because i don't want them to
be deported and have to leave their kids
and that kind of thing but
i want to make sure that i do not want
amnesty for them they can't
jump in line uh for a pathway to
citizenship
that type of thing they can't take
advantage of our health care
and welfare and that type of thing they
have to work and pay taxes so
i'm kind of okay with that what should
be the
approach from the government moving
forward when it comes to
um the sale the preservation how do you
handle
especially nevada our public lands
um i want to preserve our public lands
for the people
i'm not for blocking people from going
on them
like some of the blm the bureau of land
management has done
recently or some of what they want to do
actually
so i'm for preserving that and i don't
want to yeah i don't want to sell it i
don't want
uh to take these lands away from people
that
want to use them
now we do have that full interview
including marchand's take on mail and
election ballots on our website
8newsnow.com just look for the 2020
election interviews tab
under news we have invited congressman
horsford on in the coming weeks as well
well her horse for excuse me has been
campaigning online like most other
candidates during this time
on tuesday he held a zoom town hall with
the human rights campaign president
and democratic state senator dallas
harris it focused on
lgbtq rights the 2020 census
and vote by mail let's take a look at
the voter registration in congressional
district 4. this is a seat that has been
held by both republicans and democrats
in the last few cycles
according to the nevada secretary of
state there are more than 167
000 registered democrats in the district
compared to about
128 thousand republicans so democrats
have built almost
40 000 voter registration advantage
there are also a little more than 91
thousand 800 people registered as
nonpartisan
coronaviruses of course front and center
during this time of campaigning
on contrast i'm running against a guy
who
has been a proponent of repealing the
affordable
care act we interview congresswoman
susie lee about the federal response so
far
and if she could debate her opponent dan
rhodeimer that's next on politics now
your news your nation
now let's take a look at congressional
district 3 incumbent democrat suzy lee
hoping for a second
term she'll have to beat republican dan
rodimer who is a
former professional wrestler restaurant
owner he has not yet served in political
office
john langler talked with the
congresswoman about our coronavirus
response
and the possibility of debates your
opponent would also suggest that the
the handling by the trump administration
of the uh of the pandemic has been
um reasonably sound
what's unsound about how things have
gone
you know we have 152 000 americans who
have died
852 nevadans over 50 000 nevadans who
have contracted this virus this is
the response to this pandemic should
have been a national
strategy it should have been a strategy
in testing it should have been a
strategy
and procurement of what we needed to
conduct those tests
and instead this president basically
abdicated all responsibility
and basically said you states go do it
yourself
and what that meant is a state like
nevada had to compete with california
in new york in michigan to get the
reagents and the supplies to conduct our
testing
it it clearly resulted in us having a
tough time
you know we're now doing a significant
amount of tests but it took a while for
us to get that
and you saw a long turnaround in terms
of getting the results for testing
and guess what now we're seeing a spike
again we're seeing a delay in getting
test results back
i feel that this administration should
have come out strong in the very
beginning
and adopted a nationwide testing
strategy
and prevention strategy i'm even the
fact that
the president has not worn a mask up
until
once about three weeks ago i mean we
know that the science is clear this is
an airborne disease
and wearing a mask prevents its
transmission just some significant
leadership of that
would have saved thousands of lives in
this country do you care too do you have
any interest in
debating uh him at all listen i think
that any time
people in congressional district 3 can
learn more about me and my opponent and
understand
my track record of 25 years in this
community of rolling up my sleeves and
taking on significant issues
and basically coming to washington with
that same
that same drive and by the way i've
been ranked as one of the most
bipartisan members of congress
i have uh set out and passed legislation
that has helped students
with student debt helped reduce
prescript you know prescription drug
prices
so i have a clear track record um i you
know i think it's good
for our constituents to be able to draw
that distinction
really against an opponent who has
literally
a track record of some very disturbing
and dangerous behavior
you can watch that full interview on
eight news now dot com look for the 2020
elections interviews tab
under news we do plan to have road eimer
on next week you can watch our previous
interview with him
prior to the primary that's found under
the same tab as well
rodrimer has the support of top national
republicans this week house republican
leader kevin mccarthy announced that
he was being elevated to the top tier of
its 2020 young guns program
this program requires candidates work
towards specific benchmarks
to make sure their race is competitive
and well
funded